this is the Somali wild-ass at less than  700 left in the wild these graceful  creatures are fighting for survival they  top out at around 4 feet at the shoulder  and can reach speeds up to 30 miles per  hour ole gray with a white belly their  lower legs are striped like zebras they  come from the desert where conditions  are tough as the lack of rainfall  provides minimal food and water but  these creatures are survivors dating  back over 6,000 years at one point they  roamed across the entire arabian  peninsula but today only a small few  scattered around Eritrea Ethiopia and  Somalia they've been hunted to  near-extinction for their meat and  medicinal purposes  besides being hunted their access to  water has been getting scarcer and  scarcer as farmers have taken over this  is the Somali wild-ass